rocket League developer psionic Studios
has discussed becoming the first game to
sabor cross networked multiplayer
between the Xbox one and PlayStation 4
saying has already figured out the
technology necessary to bridge the two
communities speaking in an interview
with GameSpot psionics vice-president
Jeremy Dunham said that the only thing
left to work out was the politics of the
arrangement the only thing we have to do
now is to sort out where we stand
politically with everyone and then it's
full steam ahead to finish the solution
that we've already started
technologically everything works we've
got it all figured out just a little bit
of time to get everything up and running
right now excitement is the best way to
put it we just want to get in there and
make it happen
elation is probably another word I'd use
we're just excited although Microsoft
has extended an invitation to other
platforms and networks to connect Xbox
Live Sony has not yet committed to
opening up the PlayStation Network to
Xbox players continuing Dunham's said
that connecting the Xbox one's rocket
league community with those in the
PlayStation 4 MPC is important to the
overall health of the game there's this
weird psychological thing that happens
with people if you let them know that
their community is small even though
they're enjoying the game and playing it
there's this weird effect where
sometimes it encourages them to stop
playing if they think no one else is
going to play with them which creates a
snowball effect where other people stop
playing because they don't think
anyone's going to play in addition to
creating a large pool of players a
shared community would also allow
psionics to make new features and
updates ubiquitous across all platforms
the more people you have to throw in
there the less likely the psychological
anomaly will kick in then you have the
actual reality of it which is more
players for everyone means more games
and more games means more participation
and community feedback which we can then
put into the game as a whole I don't
have to worry about siloing off certain
features on certain platforms because
this version doesn't have it whatever
the situation may be
as previously mentioned sony has not yet
confirmed where playstation players will
be able to connect on Xbox one players
currently raka Lee's cross-platform
connectivity will only bring together
Xbox one and PC communities the
PlayStation 4 version also supports
cross-platform multiplayer with PC so
can you envision a world where the
console wars are no more and we can all
drive cars into giant balls together let
us know in the comments section below or
find me on Twitter at irregular Dave and
for all your gaming news stay tuned to
Games
calm